because
democracy is precious I'm going to
Ukraine I've been setting my mind of why
I'm going and I know it's a just cause
sixteen thousand foreigners have joined
in the fight on the ground in Ukraine on
Monday the country temporarily lifted
visa requirements for foreigners making
it easier for them to come in and get
after it they're here to fight I have to
fight I I will fight Ukraine's president
called on foreigners to join a newly
formed International defense Legion to
bolster the country's Army he hailed
them all as Heroes and thousands of
people from around the world have been
answering that call
some are joining Ukraine's Armed Forces
others are trying to get to the battle
on their own
okay let's go Ukraine's government has
actively recruited foreigners to join
the fight over 20 thousand have
reportedly expressed interest and many
Americans are showing up daily giving up
everything at home in order to take on
the Russians
food
I feel so unhappy
[Music]
I keep thinking I shall never see him
again
my father is a very ordinary man there's
no criminal thief or member of any mafia
they have no proof I've not done
anything
that's the way it is
[Music]
help us purchase this property to build
the Deeds Center
donate right now may God Almighty Allah
reward all of you brothers and sisters
guys how are you doing we're continuing
meeting some people here in Bosnia and
we're going to continue on I just
visiting someone who was a friend of the
former president of
the Bosnia country
aliazabegovic he's a good friend of his
someone who the grand muftes of Bosnia
would come and visit
and someone who has gone through some
tribulations and tough times and has
learned from many of these things
someone who is grown with age and wisdom
has come so we want to see uh some of
his experiences sharing with you many of
you maybe have seen him on Al Jazeera
he's been on many of the networks all
over the globe
here with Abu Hamza salaam alaikum
how are you doing now good good check
now can you tell us now
um
there was an interesting story you were
sharing with us that you were working
um in some kind of met you were studying
medicine and you were in a situation
where you you saw a a young girl that
had been raped and it touched your heart
so much and this is around the beginning
of the time of the war and this kind of
motivated you to to want to go and and
help the um the Muslim people who were
being persecuted and the genocide was
being done against them in the former
Yugoslavia is that correct yes when the
beginning of the war I was in Croatia in
rieka and the refugees from Bosnia come
to riecka and in one place
they come one father and five daughter I
think the older one have about 414 years
14 14 years and she
saw his her mother when the Chutney it's
rabbit and she after that have Civic
problem don't talking don't go to WC
about six months don't go to the WC
after that we trying to help her about
we cannot because we are like individual
we cannot help here and when I saw that
I decided to come to Bosnia to help the
people in Boston Herzegovina the Muslim
in Boston University going what what can
you because the majority of the world
they don't know or they've forgotten
it's a forgotten history but can you
talk about the for in a brief moment
bringing people up to speed on is it
true that this was after World War II
the one of the greatest genocide that
happened was in Bosnia
look uh the problem now uh the media
make this yes they was that it was again
one side you can't see in celebrities in
breedor in Doughboy in in in in Sarajevo
they killed the innocent people in the
beginning of the war yugoslavan Army was
the weapons they have everything and the
people the Muslim in Boston they don't
have anything when they come to City
they kill the innocent people the
civilian people they don't kill any
soldiers because there is no soldiers in
the village not soldiers in breedor in
kosaratsan there is no no they killed
the man the old man they killed the
woman the child and they say we make a
history and we come back Bosnia to the
chetnik or to Big Serbia
now nowadays there is a lot of emphasis
on this term radical Islam they will
always try to connect you know people uh
saying that Islam is the cause of this
but uh during is it true that during
this this uh genocide that people like
milosevic uh karajich these were
practicing Christians but we don't blame
Christianity do we I mean and and you
never hear anything mentioned about
anything about religion or or whatnot uh
look we must make a difference between
Jewish and Tunisia we must make a
difference between for example milosevic
and the Serb like uh uh like people
people or like uh religion because
milosevic he have idea big Serbia and he
used the Christianity he used the Serb
for his big and he say for the Christ we
make big Serbia and for example and this
is what we must make different miloshi
which is not Christian uh carajis is not
a Christian he have political or he have
one idea in his his head and he wants uh
through the religion to succeed with the
people and he used the religion for that
now you have a lot of experience you
know coming up now what are some of the
the things that you've gained in time
with age with experience you know
there's a lot of overzealous you know
people who maybe just take into the
religion and maybe they you know end up
uh you know they're young they're not
experienced what what do you what advice
do you give with all the experience that
you've gained over time to some of the
overzealous you know you've sometimes
who might have some extreme approach to
religion I think if we succeed
with the young people to brought them
and to be now good Muslim we can change
his appear because
we can't change his Banton to be short
about the big problem that changed the
man from inside that's meaning you work
with the people we work with and the
young people and the young people become
a Muslim before Islam he was in
jahiliate and he only changed his
outside he don't change his inside this
is the problem you know he is still this
the same man in jahiliate for example he
drink alcohol he's he's not good man
when he change to be a Muslim he lit his
beard he can make a short uh his button
on short but he don't change his
behavior we will have a problem that in
the face you must change your behavior
to be good Muslim with with your Heckman
with your family and after that you can
make success it in your outside tell us
also you you've also
um have had some controversial things
that have come up in your time you know
and can you explain you know put things
in context how uh you went from having
an actual citizenship Here and Now
what's what's going on now uh with that
the problem is come after 11
when 11 September when they all the
world is against Muslim and we here in
Bosnia some of British of United States
or European country in Boston University
that these people who come to help the
Bosnian people must get out and they
have only when we take our ship our
citizenship from us and kick us from uh
out of Bosnia and they succeed uh in
some case of that alhamdulillah I can
use I use is the right to go to
Strasbourg Strasburg and stop my
deportation to my country to Syria and I
am I think now succeed I was about seven
and a half year in the Immigration
Center about after that now I am now in
with my family and it's it's so
difficult about everything they make it
traded the national
anzegovina in the secret
uh time Dockers how to say proof Bruce
is in the secret room I don't know why
why I am a danger about you are danger
only for that reason now one of the
things that we over at the din show we
try to dispel many of the myths
misconceptions and whatnot and one thing
that you know nowadays many people
associate uh many of some of these
Fringe elements like daesh some people
say the Islamic State we call it the
insane state right and many of these
groups instead might do some things
opposite to Islam what what do you say
do do people try to link you or do you
have any affiliation with such you know
radical groups or whatnot have you ever
been labeled with uh any of these uh
extreme radical elements in my opinion
it's that Jihad before 20 or 30 years is
not the same Jihad now because in the
time of of for example Sheikh Abdullah
or or another people before him there
was a real mujahid that's meaning you
must look for everything around of you
not you are for example is
Khalifa and you can do everything we
don't accept this way of Islam this I
think easily it's make it somebody make
it easily to take and to kill the Sunnah
in Iraq in Syria in Libya etc etc they
make excuse that the people come
and after that they come to kill the
Muslim
we we must open our mind we must open
our heart to see the truth is it's not
our way of Islam
so this has uh this is something that
you have no part with nothing to do with
at all
I saw a before and now and I said before
that we don't accept and we we in Boston
we we have some people like that he want
to behavior like that we kick him them
out of uh Jihad our Jihad because you
must be the right way of Sunnah
muhammadina and we don't accept this way
of jihad like Isa or etc etc etc what
are what are their advice uh do you give
you know from the things that you've
seen living here in Bosnia you've been
here for how long now it's about 30
years I come here in
1982 in exchugoslavia and I think
you can succeed with the people with
your behavior it's better for us to be
dire without to talking and the people
to see the change in your behavior and
the Islam in your behavior is then to
talking
thousands of their service thousands of
shares to come to talking if you
Behavior like a Muslim a real this is
very difficult to behavior like a good
Muslim in Europe now in Europe for
example now in Bosnia with your mind
with your family with your cousin with
your neighbor to behavior like a Muslim
it's better than to talking about Islam
so so so much because the people want to
see example how the Islam is living not
in the book there's one thing that many
people are are confused about uh is that
now you're someone who is kind of
without uh
an identity almost you know what's your
situation now and is that going to
change at all you went from someone who
was who was given by the former
president uh I believe ali azabegovic uh
you were given you know a citizenship
you were welcome what changed did you
did you do something did you did you
piss somebody off you know did you upset
somebody that now that all of that's
been taken away you sat in jail for
seven years seven and a half yeah did
you make a mistake are you sorry for it
fill us in I think this is example for
me and another brother
did we come to Bosnia in the name of
Allah to help the Muslim all the people
of us if you come in the name of Allah
you don't be uh sad because you lost
your citizenship you don't be sad
because they put you in the jail you
don't be sad to take you everything
because you come here for Allah and
Allah be happy or Allah
happy with you this is the question if
you come for that it's no problem
citizenship take it won't be kicked out
kick out about I will still a Muslim and
I like our brother and Muslim and
another time if they need to come to
help the Bosnian people I will come to
help them because Allah order me not
Aliyah not Bosnian people
etc etc can you uh summarize the things
that we went over if you remember and
it's Unique to you not only speak
English but you also speak fluent
Bosnian the points that you we went over
can you kind of summarize them and also
you know for the for the Bosnian viewers
that are out there that are going to
probably watch can you say what you've
said the questions I had can you
summarize it and repeat it in the
Bosnian language in the Bosnian language
okay
you have uh any uh yes
suggestions comments or anything as we
wrap up this interview that you'd like
to say a message that you want to give
out and you can do it in English and
Bosnia
for our brother in Syria in in Sham in
Iraq in everywhere that Allah give him
give them the the power that to be
patient and to change himself if we
don't change him ourselves we cannot
succeed another thing to our uh
yes
thank you very much
so can you elaborate on this so he's
never been officially charged with
anything uh nor was so now what are the
restrictions put on him he's never been
trying to do a crime there's no yeah
already you know from talking to him a
few days ago that basically he was in
prison
similar thing what happened in us with
Patriot Act there was some new laws test
which approved the government to put
people in prison without any firm proof
so that's what had to actually happen to
him and even after he got out of prison
the prime minister of internal security
he said that he was in prison under
secret evidence and this evidence was
refused to be shown even to his lawyers
to anybody so they and there were never
any charges that were raised against him
or any
convictions nothing so that that's why
he's out of prison today because it's
out of any law in the world to keep
somebody in prison for seven and a half
years without any charges without any
procedure so that's possible here in
Bosnia because Bosnia has not been any
in European Union basically which where
you cannot keep somebody for 30 days
maybe I think or 60 without the process
is it true that he was very good friends
with the former uh president uh Ali
isabagovic and and some of the the mo
the um the grand Mufti Za Bosnia they
they never really had a problem with him
and they were close friends with him is
that correct yeah
did he pay all his parking tickets did
he get any parking tickets did did he
was he ever a threat at all in in the
neighborhood that any neighbor neighbors
complain about him from the smallest no
absolutely
um
foreign
thank you
with U.S now lastly he never had any
conflict for Neighbors no parking
tickets that he didn't pay nothing so
and he actually had really good support
from all his friends and neighbor
neighbor story people that vouched for
him that he was a good character a good
uh citizen
that she works in Al Jazeera which is
international corporation media
Corporation where she had contact with
people from Serbia Croatia who followed
his case through this period because she
weren't there and they all supported
this and trying to to put this uh
pressure social like pressure of the
environment to the government to to let
him out of prison sooner so and when he
got out of prison it was he was really
uh greeted well with people who are
Muslims and who are not Muslims also who
would understand what's happening and
this is just like sunscreen political
story
is there anything that the uh the
community at large can can do to be a
voice for for someone who seems like is
is pretty much being uh oppressed
um foreign
foreign
showing us how this tribulation that
happened to them showed them also the
faces of many people around and there
were many of the of the very good
friends of her father that never even
came to visit him or he was in prison
which surprised them because they were
probably afraid about political
consequences that their positions you
mentioned earlier that he had some also
government uh government people from the
government who were his friends who
supported him and they had admitted with
him during the war many times because he
was PR of this group in the war so after
when he was in prison these people never
never there never there to support him
to even visit him bring him chocolate or
something Embrace him and then on the
other side he had some people who they
would never expect that would come and
find a way to visit him to give him some
support but
you know all in all what she's saying it
was that them as the children as his
children were thinking how they could
help him their father was always telling
them the best thing you could do is to
finish your colleges to go finish all
the education be your best Buchanan it
proved to them that this is the best
thing they could do but to do something
directly to help and to bring some
awareness to press the
any system to protect this Injustice
that was out of anybody's reach is his
door open for people if they want to
come talk with them here here a story uh
be it from you know whoever in the world
wants to come and just meet him to see
what kind of person he is of course our
doors are always opened and everyone is
welcome to come in here to sit with us
we're gonna coffee or something so
before we end is it pretty much that if
uh he basically has a home but he
doesn't this is where it's like you said
it's very confusing is it where if a
country now let's say someone's watching
this someone who uh runs a small country
and they wanted to accept him can he go
to that country how does it work is he
restricted here
um
foreign
some people who were in similar
situations and then they chose they were
chosen to be exported to Switzerland and
then after five years during this period
of prohibition to be embodia expired
then they again deported them out of
Switzerland to Bosnia so basically it's
really confusing the situation playing
with these people so then one of the
guys the same guy was then being exposed
to descend back to Afghanistan which is
we now know very unstable and dangerous
area so and her father she's giving us
another more background on him he
actually came to Bosnia in 1983 when he
was 18 years old so imagine if somebody
lives in U.S from 1983 by now he would
be long-lasting and standing citizen of
U.S and here in Bosnia he needs to he
doesn't have any papers or cannot prove
that he is Bosnian that he has all the
rights to be here when he's married has
kids and the living beautiful how many
30 and more years now with and she's
basically saying that he is now more
Bosnian than it than any other national
team he has four rights to to be here
any closing comments or any uh thing you
want to uh let us know you came here
your welcome in Boston and you can
always come
if it doesn't
send a lot thank you very much can you
translate that all right thank you guys
so much thank you
wake up there are over 300 million
Americans that don't know what Islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
Center the first of its kind 35
000 square foot Tower Center and Masjid
to show America the Beautiful Message of
Islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch Nationwide tower programs a
state-of-the-art Production Studio for
online content and an on-site dawa
Center to show what true Islam is donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
foreign